hey this is me winning the Super Bowl
oh are you gonna do the just just shake
it out alright y'all the big game is
almost here and to celebrate we're
having a Puppy Bowl right here on the
show it's awesome I love my job
and since I know a thing about coaching
you know one or two things I'm because I
know if you've seen this little show
called the voice that I want to few
times I've got some skills that I'm
ready to show these puppies for the big
game and I guess you could call it a pup
talk you know so let's get this the baby
started guys okay
that was like a Breeden you know guys
I've been working on this play and I
think it's a surefire thing like it's
basically what you're gonna do you're
just gonna run to the right no that's
the left Dante try
what's up lots a you have been killing
it
yes you want to talk about it let's talk
about it hey okay yeah you want tell me
a secret has someone been doing your
wrong so yeah get in there
yeah yep yep what I really need you to
focus on is just not taking a dump on
the fields Michael no eating the neck of
another player it's definitely frowned
upon that's not that there's a code you
go out there and you solve equations do
it yeah equations replace what it looks
like an equation to sound it's fine now
get out there on the fields and make
mama proud or don't come home at all I'm
just kidding I love them please adopt
all these beautiful little puppies
they're so sweet and they are ready to
go to a forever home okay so please
please adopt if you're looking for a
puppy
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this